voici ce qui reste de l'Église
catholique de la commune de Cavaillon
anama de béton des images de plus en
plus habituel dans le département du Sud
qui est très touchée par le séisme 5
jours après le tremblement de terre on
espère encore trouvé des survivants dans
les décombres le dernier cadavre a été
extirper avant-hier des sapeurs-pompiers
dépêcher de Cap-Haïtien dans le nord du
pays sont venus prêter main-forte le
travail concernant le faire des canons
avec peu de moyens Saint-Cyr 28 ans pour
couper le béton pour faire la
pénétration mais on n'a pas de m'appeler
on est obligé de faire ça
à essence
la personne il y a des il y a des hommes
nous sommes arrivés on entend des gens
là à l'intérieur mais on n'a pas de
matériel pour une situation impossible
ils disent qu'ils ont les ressources
humaines mais pas matériel pour sauver
des vies
rapidement on n'a jamais connu un
tremblement de terre
mais les besoins sont urgents
on a besoin de l'eau on a besoin de
nourriture on a besoin
également
le gouvernement canadien ferme travaille
étroitement avec le gouvernement haïtien
et qu'il va à louer à Fondettes de 5
million de dollars en attendant la
population s'organise
un sac de riz sur sa moto duplex à Mazan
décide de prendre les choses en main
pour aider les communautés vulnérables
comment tu achètes
y
a pas de boss
le boss
de ma tête et de ma communauté nous
sommes tout près de l'épicentre du
tremblement de terre dans cette région
éloignée même les pierres tombales en
fait basculer ce samedi 7 août malgré
tout la désolation rien de mieux qu'un
match de foot pour oublier pour un
moment la crise autour il se déguise
Radio-Canada Cavaillon Haïti